fixed it fixed it fixed it fixed it
fixed it fixed
it fixed it you're welcome you're
welcome
you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome you're welcome you're welcome
you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome
[Music]
krista uh
i hope i didn't pronounce that miss i
probably did and i'm sorry
what do you say when you really hate
what your husband is wearing
like really hate it oh this is when
being passive-aggressive can really help
you know my husband typically wears
clothes i love
i mean i don't really have anything to
say to him but
my guess is if he ever wore something i
didn't like i think i would be really
passive aggressive
which is probably the worst way to
handle any situation
but i'd be like ah
that's a shirt
that's an interesting choice
for some pants
huh do a lot of
huh so that that's what you're
that's what you're wearing terrible
advice
to be passive aggressive but what are
you gonna what are you gonna do what are
you gonna say
like change you look stupid
no you gotta like be kinda nice about it
like
huh so that's
that's what you're that's what you're
wearing okay
cool cool cool cool cool
cool
[Music]
not my first choice anyway stuff like
that
you're welcome saved your marriage olive
stirs
says how to how do you keep your
relationship romantic during quarantine
times
oh that's
um how do you keep it romantic
i feel like being stuck in a house with
someone is just
by default romantic am i wrong i might
be wrong in this i think a lot of people
probably heard me say that and be like
uh what are you talking about like
obviously
i stopped trying with my appearance
um you know i stopped wearing makeup a
long time ago
i put way too much product in my hair
now i don't think i remember the last
time i put my contact lenses in
so um but
i don't know i think but also my husband
and i are like
still pretty fresh we're like a year and
a half
we're pretty fresh you got to read a
cosmo
uh i'm sure they have like
cool tips and stuff um
i'm i don't know i'm thinking like i
don't know make a mistake
make your significant other steak i
don't know
you know role play watch porn together
i don't know do that stuff that's not
really romantic but
you know it could be
it could be depends on the porn you
watch
i gotta i gotta stop you're welcome
malfunction says how do i focus on work
while working from home i love my job
but having a hard time
i don't know how do you focus on
anything when there's like a tv full of
all these possibilities in front of you
my husband's literally building a table
outside
it is loud there's drills you guys
probably can't hear it but i can
i love them so much how do i focus on
work while working from home
i love my job and having a hard time i
think about
this is so silly i think about when i
was a student
and i had a hard time focusing on my
studies when i was at home
someone said and i can't remember who it
was but there was the study that if you
put on beethoven or mozart while you're
doing work it helps you focus
better so i did that and it actually
worked
but then i would put on beethoven and i
would think about a clockwork orange and
then my mind would like
veer off into pretty
twisted things twist it but you know
clockwork orange things so yeah twisted
but anyway um
how do i focus i don't know you know
what give yourself
goals say if i do
this much work by this time i'm gonna
have some chocolate
or i'm gonna treat myself with this shot
of whiskey
i don't know i think that you'll figure
it out
turn the tv off that's my biggest
distraction and i can't do
anything without the tv
on so that's the problem with my life
anyway good luck i'm sure the fact that
you love your job too
that's pretty sweet that's great
you fixed it at she sells whiskey says
how do i get my mother a lot of like me
oh no how do i get my mother-in-law to
like me
wow oh that's rough
i don't know my mother-in-law loves me
um
that wasn't cool um
i think you need to like reach out and
have some
hang time you guys need to just hang out
i don't know did you do something
why does she not like you uh
just show her that you love your spouse
very much
usually mothers will be like hey if they
make my
son or daughter happy i should just be
happy um
maybe she's also just kind of a
miserable person and there's like
nothing you can do
i don't know how do i get my oh maybe
maybe she sucks
i don't know uh but i really hope
you do something just ask her to hang
out like do some
like bonding [ __ ] i don't know
like go to the what do you do right now
go on a walk
ask her to go on a walk and then tell
her
tell her some something really personal
about you
i don't know there's a lot more to that
that i want to ask
like why doesn't she like you is she
cool does she like most people
did you piss her off but i'm just gonna
assume you're a normal person
she's a normal person she just doesn't
like you
maybe she's too attached to her child
and she just didn't want anybody getting
in the way
of her relationship with them that's
really deep and intense
but whatever you do i'm sure if you're
just yourself
she's gonna love you i might just take
time it might just take time dude it's
kevin
says what's the first dine in restaurant
i should visit once covet season is over
dine in restaurant
oh like what what's the first restaurant
you should visit
i get it the first place i would go i
would go anywhere that has good
chicken tenders i used to go parties
with my friends and then we'd end up at
denny's
and then we'd have the chicken tenders
with ranch dressing
and there are moments when
that's all i want i just want to go to
denny's and i want to eat chicken
tenders with some ranch dressing
oh mozzarella sticks oh my god oh my god
once my friends and i went to
this horrible bar in pasadena i'm not
going to say its name but it's gross
um and if you're like hey i know a gross
bar that's probably it
um and we drank a lot and aaron blair
who works on our show
this was years ago ordered every
single appetizer on
the menu every single one
including something called a
cheeseburger pizza
and it tastes exactly like a
cheeseburger
and a pizza at the same time
i don't know if anything can get better
than that i want to say go to a nice
restaurant like a nice
you know have an experience but
sometimes
you just need to go to a denny's vani
castro says
i met a guy who lied about his height
and he's shorter than me should i
address it with him
he knows what are you gonna address are
you gonna have like a conversation like
if you didn't notice
you're shorter than i am but okay if
this is a romantic
thing then he's starting off with lying
and you have to be like listen
you and i both know that you're not
taller than i am um
i just want you to know i acknowledge
that
and you should
apologize i think later on i'd be like
remember when you said you were like six
two
but you were really 5'4
that's you you kind of lied to me about
that
but for the first like i have so many
other questions do you like this person
um do you guys get along do you care
that he's shorter than you
if none of those things apply and it's
just like he's shorter than me and i
didn't like that he lied to me
my my best advice to you could be
would just be is that something that's
worth talking about
pick your battles pick your battles
it's the best thing someone ever told me
you're welcome fixed it i'm done
i'm done